السيد ايمن الصفدي اهلا وسهلا بك كيف
تتابعون كل ما يجري حاليا الان
مساء الخير اخ محمد ورمضان مبارك وكل عام
وانتم بخير
بالطبع نتابع ما يجري بقلق وغضب شديدين
ذاك انما تقوم به اسرائيل من اعتداءات غير
مبرره على المصلين
المسالمين في المسجد الاقصى هو دفع باتجاه
التصعيد هو انتهاك لحرمه الاماكن المقدسه
وهو عمل
يخرق كل القوانين الدوليه ويحرق مسؤوليه
اسرائيل بصفاتها القوه القائمه
بالاحتلال العنف يولد العنف ونتذكر ان ما
يجري في الاقصى يجري على خلفيه غياب كامل
للافاق السياسيه التي يجب ان تاخذنا
باتجاه حل الصراع على اساس حل الدولتين
وتلبيه الحقوق المشروعه للشعب الفلسطيني
كامله باتجاه ضغوط اقتصاديه كبيره باتجاه
خطوات اسرائيليه
تقتل الامل
بالسلام من بناء المستوطنات مصادرات
لاراضي تهجير للفلسطينيه من بيوتهم
فباختصار اسرائيل تدفع المنطقه باتجاه
الهاويه وهذا امر سينعكس بشكل كبير على
الجميع
اسمعني السيد الوزير هناك اشكال في الموقف
الاردني وفي المواقف العربيه بشكل عام
خاصه المعنيه اكثر من غيرها بمعنى ان ما
تفضلت بذكره الان لا غبره عليه من الناحيه
المبدئيه ولكن لا يسحبه اي اجراء لا من
الاردن ولا من السلطه الفلسطينيه ولا من
الدول المعنيه وبالتالي فاسرائيل ليست
مجبره باي حال من الاحوال على ان تغير هذه
السياسه
سيدي لا اشكال في الموقف الاردني الموقف
الاردني والجهد الاردني
واضحان تماما الاردن يقوم بكل ما يستطيع
القيام به من اجل وقف هذه الاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه من اجل المضي في عمليه تاخذنا
باتجاه تلبيه الحقوق المشروعه للشعب
الفلسطيني الشقيق لكن الاردن وحده لم
يستطيع ان ينهي الاحتلال الاردن وحده ولم
يستطيع ان يوقف هذه الاعتداءات علينا ان
نقارب الامور عندما كان الصراع عسكريا قدم
الاردن الشهداء وارتقى الشهداء الاردنيون
على اسوار الاقصى وفي كل بقاع فلسطين
المحتله عندما صارت المقاربه سياسيه بقرار
عربي فلسطيني جامع ايضا قام الاردن بكل ما
يستطيعه حتى في اتفاقيه السلام مع اسرائيل
ضمنه
الحقوق الفلسطينيه المشروعه ومنذ ان وقعت
هذه الاتفاقيه وهذه وحتى هذه اللحظه يستمر
الاردن في توظيف كل علاقاته
الوظيفه الاتفاقيه من اجل اسناد الشعب
الفلسطيني الشقيق علينا ان نكون صريحين
الاردن ليس في موقع الان لان يكون قادرا
لوحده على التصدي للعدوان والتصدي
للاحتلال الاردني يقوم بما يستطيعه وفي
اطار الجهد السياسي والجهد العملي
الميداني لاسناد الفلسطينيين والمقدسيين
على الارض اعتقد ان العالم كله يعرف ما
يقوم به الاردن
وردود الفعل الدوليه التي تراها والمواقف
الرافضه لما تقوم به اسرائيل هذا ما رده
جهود اردنيه وعربيه وغيرها لكن الاردن في
مقدم كل الجهود التي تستهدف التصدي لما
تقوم به اسرائيل حمايه المقدسات واسناد
الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق بالتاكيد سيد
الوزير الاردن وحده لا يستطيع ان يفعل
شيئا طالما لا توجد مسانده كامله ولكن اذا
بقينا في موضوع المسجد الاقصى تحديدا
والرعايه الهاشميه للاماكن المقدسه في
القدس رغم
كل ما يجري لم نرى الاردن يتخذ خطوه عمليه
لردع اسرائيل في هذا المجال يعني مثلا
نتذكر ما طلب به مجلس النواب الاردني من
ضروره طرد السفير الاسرائيلي على على سبيل
المثال يعني لا توجد خطوه عمليه تجعل
اسرائيل تشعر بان ما تقوم به في المسجد
الاقصى على الاقل له ثمن في علاقتها مع
الاردن
اختلف معك اخي العزيز اعتقد ان الاردن
اتخذ الكثير من الخطوات ويقوم بجهد سياسي
كبير فيما يتعلق بالضغط على اسرائيل
لتعريه سياساتها وايقافها وراينا كما قلت
المواقف الدوليه ونحن كما قلت الان في
فتره الصراع فيها سياسي والجهد السياسي
الاردني له اثره الكبير لكن فيما يتعلق
مجال الاقصى لنكون واضحين دائره الاوقاف
الاردنيه ليس دورها ان تحرر الاقصى لا
تستطيع ان تقوم بذلك دورها ان تحافظ على
المسجد ان تحافظ على الاقصى وهي مثلها مثل
كل المؤسسات غير الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه
الموجوده تحت الاحتلال تواجه تحديات كبيره
غير قادره على لجم ما يقوم به الاحتلال من
اعتداءات وخروقات لكنها تقوم بدور كبير
والسؤال اذا سمحت لي ان اقاربه من منظور
مختلف ماذا كان سيحدث لو لم تكن الاوقاف
الاردنيه موجوده في الاقصى ولو لم تكن
الوصايه الهاش موجوده في الاقصى لكانت
اسرائيل
تسللت عبر الفراغ الذي تعبئه الاوقاف
الاردنيه لتفرضوا سيادتها بالكامل على على
الاقصى وعلى الحرم الشريف
لتكون اكثر قدره على تهويده وعلى تغييره
الوضع التاريخي والقانون القائم فيه الوضع
صعب جدا التحديات كبيره الاردني يقوم بما
يستطيع لكن ماذا يستطيع ان يفعل 70 حارس
من الاوقاف في مواجهه قوات الشرطه
الاسرائيليه التي يقودها الان متطرف يعرف
العالم عنصريته ويعرف ايديولوجيته
غير الانسانيه فبالتالي نضع الامور في
سياقها نعرف ان الاوقاف لا تقوم بكل ما
نريد او تريد ان ان تقوم به لكن ماذا
سيحدث لو لم تكن الاوقاف هناك ولننظر الى
الصوره بكليتها اريني اي مؤسسه غير
اسرائيليه موجوده في فلسطين المحتله قادره
على ان تقوم بكل ما تريد ان تقوم به نحن
نفعل المستطاع نكرس كل الامكانات اللازمه
تصدينا للكثير من المحاولات التي استهدفت
التهويد للمسجد وتغيير هويته
نتذكر ما جرى قبل عامين حين ارادت اسرائيل
ان تضع بوابات الكترونيه على المسجد كيف
تصدى الاردن لها وكيف كان لاتصالاته
وجهوده التي قام بها سياسيا من اثر في
ازاله هذه البوابات الصراع يومي الصراع
مستمر الاشتباك ومستمر نفعل كل ما نستطيعه
ويجب ان لا ينظر الى ما يقوم به الاردن
بمعزل عن الصوره الكليه وهي بكل صراحه
صوره صعبه صوره توجد فيها قوات احتلال
تخرق القانون الدولي تخرق الشرعيه الدوليه
تعتدي على حقوق الفلسطينيين تحاول تكرس
الاحتلال عبر عديد ممارسات في الاقصى وفي
غير الاقصى لكن الاردن مستمر في جهوده
ويتخذ كل ما يلزم الخطوات واتخذنا في
السابق خطوات كثيره عندما اعتقدنا انها
تؤدي مرادها عندما في السابق طردنا السفير
الاسرائيلي طردنا كل كادر السفاره
الاسرائيليه ولم يعودوا الا هنا نفذوا ما
كنا طلبناه منكم استعدنا الباقوره والغمر
ورفضنا وانهينا العمل بالاتفاقيه الخاصه
التي كانت تعطي لاسرائيل
دور في في استثمارها فبالتالي الاردن يقوم
بما يستطيعه وفق منهجيه واضحه واستنادا
الى ثوابت لا تتغير باننا نقوم بكل ما
نستطيع ونوظف حتى اتفاقيه السلام مع
اسرائيل من اجل الاسناد الشعب الفلسطيني
الشقيق ومره اخرى ماذا لو لم يكنه الدوري
الاردني موجود ماذا لو لم تكن الوصايه
الهاشميه موجوده ماذا لو لو لا يقوم رجال
الاوقاف الاردنيه في القدس بدورهم لنقارب
الامور من هذا المنظور
يعني اعتقد ان كما قلت سابقا اليوم هذا
جهد سياسي نقوم به
دعونا الى جلسه مجلس الامن بالتنسيق مع
جمهوريه مصر العربيه
وفلسطين والامارات العربيه المتحده كنا
دعونا الاجتماعا للجامعه العربيه ومنظمه
التعاون الاسلامي ايضا هذا جهد من العمل
السياسي لكن بالنهايه اعتقد ما يجب ان
يعرفه العالم كله اننا لا نريد للعالم ان
يتحرك فقط عندما تدفع اسرائيل المنطقه
باتجاه الهاويه على العالم ان يتحرك
لمعالجه اسباب التوتر واسباب الصراع وهي
وجود الاحتلال لن ينتهي الصراع ما بقي
الاحتلال لن يحصل الاسرائيليون على الامن
ما لم يحصل عليه الفلسطينيون وهذه هي
القضيه الاساس ما يجري في الاقصى ما يجري
في كل الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله هو
تعبير عن حاله اكبر واصعب وهي ان هناك
احتلال يجب ينتهي والعنف لا يتوقف الا اذا
توقفت اسبابه والتهدئه لن تتم الا اذا ما
توقفت الاسباب التي تحول دونها وهذا هو
الجهد الذي نقوم به السؤال الاخير سيد
الوزير فيما يتعلق بتطورات اليوم هل لديكم
اي تخوفات ما تتسع رقعه ما جرى وتهدد كل
الاستقرار في المنطقه كما كما يقال عاده
بالتاكيد
العنف يولد العنف ما تقوم به اسرائيل من
من عدوان واستفزاز
للفلسطينيين وللمسلمين وللمسيحيين ايضا
عبر اعتداءاتها على الكنائس وحرمان
المسيحيين للممارسه الحقيم بالكامل في
العباده كل هذا يوجد بيئه لن تؤدي الى
المزيد من العنف واعتقد ربما علينا ان
نفكر قليلا ايضا بان اسرائيل تواجه تحديات
داخليه كبيره هل الذهاب باتجاه التصعيد مع
الفلسطينيين والتصعيد الاقليمي مخرج لها
هذا سؤال يجب ان يطرح وبالتالي يجب ايضا
ان نقارب الامور من منظور ان لا ان تبقى
الانظار مركزه على ما تقوم به اسرائيل في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله من اعتداء على
الاقصى من حرمان المصلين من حقهم في
العباده من
قتل حل الدولتين الذي اذا قتلته اسرائيل
لن يبقى هنالك
شكرا جزيلا لك السيد ايمن الصفدي وزير
الخارجيه الاردني كنت معنا من العاصمه
الاردنيه عمان